[Musica]
bene
28 a la riduzione icona come partenza
ciao allo ragazzi ospedale
tolgo l'audio di prima sono sentite una
sega che mi metto un secondo schermo
intero che vi spiego
allora via questo countdown via tutto
via tutto via tutto ragazzi oggi siamo
un gioco che ha fatto la storia la
storia del dl di del canale ha fatto la
storia del mondo non so se avete
presente che la inside è un gioco
talmente figo che è diventato nel tempo
una delle serie di maggior successo del
canale perché lo dico ogni volta che
faccio una live su qualcosa perché io
faccio le live sulle serie di maggior
successo del canale le riporta a
distanza di anni
solo mi ricordo una sega di quello che
era inside cioè se non mi ricordo più
niente ma era di una bellezza
incredibile
oggi lo facciamo in live fichera lo
finisco sono le cinque secondo i miei
calcoli matematici avanzati via da
fisico astrofisico sono entro le otto
giorni
mi affido welcome ragazzi adesso metto
anche il gameplay
così si vede tutto ok ci siete numero
giorni come prima di allora
non so se scopro il costo degli abbonati
non era comunque ragazzi lo ricordate
più o meno come era era veramente
bellissimo c'è veramente stupendo sto
gioco
io mi ricordo l'inizio è john elkann
allora ragazzi partiamo dovresti fare
anche lingua è però limbo l'ho rifatto
troppo premier john da madonna che sta
succedendo geo grazie ragazzi che è
successo grazie grazie mille
mi dovete scusare faccio sono state mi
dovete scusare se ultimamente sto
facendo meno live del solito vi chiedo
scusa
però siccome tra un po vado vado in
vacanza anche io incredibile sto
preparando tanti video no per un
workshop welcome e quindi ho poco tempo
per fare le live però oggi avevo dalle
58 dovevo libero e allora letame
facciamo facciamola live speriamo di
ritrovare quella bellezza che era inside
del genere però vabbè si parte let's go
a giacche parte così subito è vero non
c'erano
ecco sto gioco vi piace perché non parla
non c'è nel senso non ci sono dialoghi
proprio tu giochi libri la mente c'è
un'ansia incredibile per la moglie io
però è proprio bello per questo motivo
allora io sono questa personcina qui e
sono sono non so chi sono però lo
scopriremo giocando le scotte
allora in realtà sto pensando che io vi
ripeto ho fatto questo calcolo se nome
finiamo in tre ore ma non è detto john
benvenuto federico allora non mi escono
i capelli dalla cam nou perché nel
numero madonna ma che succede oggi
quanti abbonati e che regga
grazie non so cosa dirvi grazie mille mi
escono i capelli ad avere dalla webcam
perché nel formato live non so questa
cosa sono sarebbe tutti uguali video se
no tutti uguali ha i capelli dalla
webcam i escono solo quando parlo della
mia prima volta che non mi sia rizzato
capito perché sono un assenza file i
telai per la voce ha fatto il live di
the nightmare sono passato sotto una
recinzione io giustamente non si sa chi
sono
però c'è gente nel camion venisse
partiamo partiamo da dio ha mai fatto
bene ma penso che mi ricordavo che l'ha
fatto così bene
non me lo ricordavo fosse fatto così
bene e poi non hanno più fatti così bene
belli e non hanno più fatti così belli
mai più cioè inside job inside come un
po più bello
secondo me non hanno mai numero john
zhao welcome fatevi controllare solo che
l'audio sia posto ragazzi fate vedere si
sia possibile spiega perché sia stato
interveniente cia ora vi amiche si of
solitude lo continuerò so che è molto
complicato a livello narrativo quindi il
montaggio è un casino
però lo continuerò
quindi è partito un camion diretto non
so dove prove e semi in triple siccome è
un gioco dove ti puoi facilmente in 3
pari in qualche punto datemi una mano
per cortesia va bene è un casino
no come quando fatto aiuto come faccio a
nascondermi aiuto ma non non mi ha visto
traggano ragazzi ha fatto da dio sto
gioco è fatto benissimo lo ricordo fosse
così bello e poi è strano perché mezzo
tridimensionale mezzo 2d non si capisce
niente fighissimo un po alla little big
planet anche quello giovane di the light
mese molto bello però lo avevo giocato
proprio in live mi pare no e quindi è un
po problema a farlo io ce l'ho contro i
frigoriferi ragazzi sono delle persone
orribili my friends petrolo lo
continuerò assolutamente numero com la
monarchia amico mio c'è il tasto vicino
al tasto iscriviti c'è scritto abbonati
e vi annuncio che da settembre cambierò
i testi abbonamenti perché li farò più
strani li porterei dlc di leivi di
little light per me lo chiede ancora una
persona lo farò per forza visto che lo
sta tenendo tutti ci sono dei cani aia e
can affidato qualcosa no caccia va a
posto e fatto primissimo l'ho già detto
86 volte ma vi giuro è veramente se io
lo farò a sto punto
ah no è vero perché non fatti dlc limite
leitner so che allora li faccio di
terribilmente la tua infanzia e pensa
che la mia adolescenza che sta dice
lunga aiuto cosa devo fare per spingere
ma cosa di un sicuro è cosa già tre
tasti sto gioco salto e spinta basta
nient'altro dei vari nient'altro
e vi assicuro che non è semplice cioè
quanto mi ricordo io almeno un giorno lo
so mi ricordo allora io sono stop
bambino senza faccia tra l'altro non
trova madonna ragazzi ma che sta
succedendo oggi grazie no i cani meno
visti carico che si ritrova a scendere
da una montagna
e ci sono delle persone aiuto non ci
credo sono vivo ce l'ho fatta soc
mamma mia che gioco assurdo del
linguaggio
al limite si ritrova a dover scappare da
questa sorta di non capisce bene che
cos'è che deportano se persone ma non si
capisce dove man mano si scoprono cose
un gioco un po strano ma merita
tantissimo
ritornerò con lite leitner settimana
prossima ragazzi lo prometto perché a
sto punto una settimana ne faccio
un'altra live show di the nightmare lo
prometto perché mykonos atene dopo john
lo faccio oggi non so che gli sta
succedendo non è stato abbonando tutti
grazie
aiuto aiuto aiuto ai sotto l'ha visto ha
visto un sacco di volte prison break
quindi so come cavarmela in queste
situazioni
ho abbassato un pelo volume degli
abbonati perché secondo me mi stordisce
e su di lui però così è troppo basso
classe ivan sei molto gentile ok dolo
proporzionato andiamo avanti porto gli
occhiali oggi ragazzi perché dopo un po
entrò nel mood di non farmi male troppo
agli occhi quindi li metto ma non è che
porto gli occhiali e sonda riposo ma sta
macchina qua c'è qualcuno dentro perché
mi sta puntando proprio in faccia ecco
lo sapevo
corri corri corri aiuto madonna l'ansia
torri dio
e vabbè aiuto e va beh niente ma la
mazza sono morto veramente mi hanno
ammazzato a non me lo ricordavo strada
quindi non devo farmi ammazzare va bene
ma questo che mi segue c'è lo fai per
non farmi ammazzare ma scusami hyatt
non ci credo sono inciampato nel tronco
va dai workshop liga
quanto durerà la live finché lo finisco
inside ragazzi tanto non credo duri pd
un paio d'ore teoricamente google chrome
forse due o tre non mi ricordo però
teoricamente dovrebbe dare tantissimo
aiuto e cosa faccio qua sto fermo va
dietro cosa faccio
ma non è vero non mi ha preso ma dai ma
ero dna guardero dietro ero dietro mi è
difficile però non mi ricordavo così
difficile 3 paese che divertente mamma
mia e mio papà che raccontava un sacco
di barzellette da quando lo dicono gli
occhiali sono da mezzo grado non hanno
gradito gradi gradazione zero se non
solo da riposo dai nomi sparare ti prego
non mi sparano mi sparano misura non ha
sparato stavolta è pazzo aiuto ce l'ho
fatta
aia ha mancato perfetto un soggetto vice
prefetto ce l'ho fatta
google chrome proprio lui
no ragazzi non ci posso credere
dio esiste o a posto non ci è successo
veramente impazzito non sapeva è
veramente difficile ragazzi ma veramente
figo aspettavo di salire di nuovo anche
io non vedevo l'ora di giocarla in live
qua c'è gente là sopra quindi immagine
mi debba buttare giù e notare noto i'm
nothing non sono ben sicuro di quanto
respiro ciò esatto una lontra morta cia
più respiro di me però fa niente non ho
visto è in tutto questo quindi è giusto
così pure poteva piove pure piove anche
loro ma ti piace la banana dipende devi
restare sott'acqua non è vero
c'è ma titoli royce e già e ragionata
delle palle deve pure piovere pure ci
manca solo questo
comunque mi piace il fatto che non si
sappia niente di questa persona voglio
voglio io aspetto la mia vita aspetto
solo che i creatori di inside e limbo
facciano un altro inside ma riguarda me
lo compro baqmi costa 600 euro glieli do
tutti me ne sbatto le balle li vale
tutti
so gioco qua non mi ricordo quanto cosa
stava tipo 15 euro ragali vale vale il
doppio
farai delle pause non lo so ma se le
farò brevi quindi non praticamente no
i pulcini che figoli schiaccio ma sta
scherzando non farei mai così sono ma mi
seguono ma che carini
oh mio dio sono bellissimi ma non mi
voglio fare le mamme seguitemi che
teneri c'è un altro amici miei del dei
pulcini venite seguitemi
c'è un segreto alla fine non ho idea di
quale se però spendere ho lasciato dei
pulcini indietro io vi voglio tutti io
seguitemi tutti tutti oddio ci sono i
maiali morti chi se ne frega basta che i
pulcini sono vivi che figata raga
l'ex clive davis devo deve entrare
dentro immagino si perché la porta non
si apriva vorrei mi seguono i pulcini
anche da solo bene e degrado che stiamo
andando in fabbrica c'è un pulcino in
fabbrica c'è un pulcino è il cugino via
[Musica]
possono fare questa rosa deve fare qua
ragazzi non mi ricordo niente di inside
day che è lì che è fantastico perché
almeno mi
mi me lo godo come se fosse la prima
volta dopo i liberi ferite ho aperto la
porta per i pulcini giustamente finite
amici che teneri cosa facciamo qua amici
datemi una mano non so cosa devo fare
qui devo tirare questo è partito ma che
lo fa devo far cadere quella roba lì da
software ha però non capito come si
ricordi di ciucci al certo martina
voglia è veramente figo quel gioco
devono entrare i pulcini lì dentro è
come faccio tutti alla leva la leva
aspira pulcini venite amori miei però ha
forse devo devo attivarlo quando john
manico e rincorrere attivarlo quando
loro sono più o meno li pira greco na
sparati può eccoli grazie ragazzi non è
morto è morto e uno e morto non si muove
ma sono un bastardo no merito di morire
mi ammazzo ti prometto che il primo
punto dovevamo ammazzo no è morto un
pulcino sono un maledetto no sheen check
in o pulcini giustamente belga del
climbing
mi dici la tua mornin routine
mi sveglio il gioco forza luminosità dei
computer ma ragazzi
il gioco è buio cioè non sono io e buio
il gioco è buio proprio cioè non vedi
che non puoi far più di troppo
cosa fai facevo così però è buio proprio
il gioco capito non è che posso fare
miracoli ma è giusto ci sono ne acquista
il salto di assassin's creed loco
imporci 18 let's go maiali non fatelo a
casa si esalta the sun cose di maiali da
70 metri morite lo stesso però qua no
immagino che debba spingerlo sì
portiamoci mai a rieti i pulcini erano
bellissimi bellissimi peccati sono un
proprio un pezzo di merda o ucciso dei
pulcini favolosi
dove stiamo andando ma io non ho capito
dove stiamo andando certo bambino da
dove che esce cioè c'era appunto da dove
è uscito perché non è possibile
ok ma vedete quanto è fatta bene sta
roba l'ho detto cioè per la quinta volta
mi ha veramente fatto benissimo
porca vacca visto impiegato occhio era
un maiale o aiuto ma cosa vuoi da me ma
non ho fatto niente
fa tanto sto veramente schivando il
maiale così oggi è la sei cercata non mi
carichi più sono stato bravissimo
ecco cav h basta certamente devo
schivarlo saltandoci sopra spiegatevi il
senso arco demonio infilati nel buco a
notti la torta è stata ma che schifo
ce l'hai un verme nel culo ma ci avevi
un bel vice l 8 salvato visto sono stato
bravissimo
posso darti come climbing anno posso
spostarlo va bene mi scusi lei mi faccio
tizio la giudizio lavori
no questa scena non la possiamo guardare
censuriamo consoliamo st scena per
cortesia e devo devo fare cosa giacché
contro la v la gente mi ero dimenticato
che controlli su gioco poi controllare
la gente qualcosa mammamia geniale avevo
fatto tirasso cosa devo tirare questo
devo aprire la gabbia ok perfetto
ok ok siete in 4 perfetto adesso potete
andare a distruggere qualsiasi cosa
avete distruggere non so neanche cosa
sto facendo ragazzo eccolo
tutto distrutto numero john ragazzi
state lì che arrivò ciao paolo grazie
mille sito del disegno jbl me lo ricordo
molto bello
thank you comunque mi sono stato molto
bravo e sono stato veramente bravo
fino adesso sono morto solo due volte
probabilmente ai de pierro morto molte
più volte dico si sa che belle le
giornate soleggiate
siamo a chernobyl ma cosa ti servono gli
occhiali a conquistare il mondo fate
schifo ma si tanto radiazioni proprio
che un piacere
vuoi col camion di prima c'è la gente
ciao gente stanno lì loro stanno lì va
bene grazie ivan marcia 10.000 iscritti
proprio come eseguito per primo
praticamente grazie non so anche cosa
devo raggiungere con l'affare lì no a
devo spingerlo mi sa mi sa che devo
avvicinarlo per respingerlo credo esatto
così ci arrivo perfetto lo stesso
pulsante qui hanno niente che mi piace
veramente tanto gioco incredibile
ragazzi stai giocando la tastiera no sto
giocando con il controller c'è una sedia
tra l'altro qual cosa mi serve perché
mamma mia quando uscirà un altro gioco
come tra l'altro io inside o altri
pulcini ragazzi non mi state vicino che
io sono un pezzo rock show room schifo
nella vita non merito nulla mi sono
distratto un attimo gli ho persi sono
volati via
va bene come non detto
siamo in questa fabbrica ancora non ho
capito cosa qual è l'obiettivo ma va
bene che quello non è che non mi ricordo
proprio qual è l'obiettivo di inside
miccoli economico non è che come finisce
come il fatto perché non mi dicono come
finisce
new york com welcome amico mio
credo di doverlo mettere qui questo
credo immagino che lo salta ma non ci
arrivo
urca vacca non mi fido dove scontarli ma
non ci arriverò mai forse devo spingerlo
sotto tantissimo a noi devo girarlo
giustamente ok chiaro effetto
e giocando la ps4 no sto giocando dal
computer con il joystick quello di sea
of thieves tra l'altro quant'è bello sto
joystick non avete idea
ok ok
urca c'è una cassaforte sono tornati gli
uccelli fanno bene a scappare perché io
faccio schifo dopo spaccare il terreno
li cavalca no ho dato una testata della
madonna ottimo succedere sono cadute
sono morto e scusatemi ragazzi ho dato
una testata no c'era la giustamente
scherzo epico finito male vabbè mi si è
pagato secondo arrivo aspettato un
attimo ragazzi che mi sembra gata la
virtuale della cia non riavviare intanto
youtube si basa su sta roba non so
perché
ok ora ci credo ma scusate mi riprendo
tutto ma lo spingo e corrono corri ai
vai ce l'ho fatta stavolta ce l'ho fatta
perfetto per scendere fin lì non ho
capito neanche cosa stiamo andando a
fare lì però va bene ma non la casa del
demone dei morti non de papel ciò la
rapina alla zecca delle persone senza
faccia le ultime tele che sono vestito
di rosso però non credo che gli servono
i soldi della zecca sua quella la
navicella spaziale o che google ha una
volta è fatta bene l'ombra
ma che bello bellissimo continuerai no
penombra necrologi certo l'ho iniziato
lo finisco questa roba qua tra server o
cos'è beh forse devo seguire soccavo che
va a fin lassù quindi no non ho ben
capito cos'era con la roba di pavia
chissene frega un tizio salve tutto bene
beh cosa ho fatto non so stare qua
comando ha giustamente comando il tizio
al bene cosa succede a mio dio che
casino a che serve sta roba scusa
controllo sti 2 tm che cito fa aspetta
aspetta aspetta società
cos'è quella roba in alto a destra che
cambia a mar ci sono le piazze è infatti
non capivo ma ci sono sei piattaforme
per terra ma un lavoro mica viste che
pirla ma che pirla non lavora anche
visto ho capito come faccio
come faccio a versare 1 ferme far
muovere con l'altro michael jackson non
ho capito che faccia star far a far star
fermo uno e l'altro no mas tale va in
stalle vacua scusate mi sa che cosa che
serve oggi
madonna non stava schiacciando
fortissimo che adesso ho capito che devo
aprirla vi faccio entrare tutti e due
chiudo uno va da una parte o dall'altra
perfetto un casino bello che corre a
vuoto il mio personaggio va bene ce l'ho
fatta verso la luce dove vai in vacanza
allora vado a new york boston
washington come sangio marchigiane bang
da new york e so contento a belfast
alive siamo usciti quindi sono fuori
dalla fabbrica ufficialmente eletto mi
piace rischiare nella vita quando la
prossima volta che andrà in giappone
deve passare almeno un po di tempo come
quando guardo ha riportato nel passare
almeno un annetto e poi ci vado no in
giappone dovrà passare almeno almeno
almeno un paio d'anni un paio d'anni e
poi posso di tornarci secondo me sono
vivo troppo lì c'è gente prove di che
c'è gente che li controlla quindi e tipo
una roba del contratto
secondo me c'è stata l'apocalisse quando
finisco sto gioco devo leggermi devo
ricordarmi che devo leggere in un
attimino delle silicio dei delle teorie
delle teorie su inside per capire bene
che trama è perché mi ricordo che non la
spiegano mai nessuno mai parla e non si
capisce mai so che c'è chi è gente che
fa esperimenti su altra gente corrie ok
per ora non ho ben capito il senso il
fine non so se c'è stata l'apocalisse
non si capisce nulla
non so neanche se è collegato a limbo
per per assurdo google.com welcome orco
demonio sono stupido pensavo ci fosse il
modo per scendere la scala la al tubo
più velocemente
le teorie lg live si si si
vorrei le giorni in live ma anche roba
che ansia c'è questa è una specie
ragazzi fermi tutti alexa metti thriller
di michael jackson thriller di michael
jackson da amazon music no all ex art
togli thriller di michael jackson
adesso ci penso che copia di michael
extra inizia ora l'ex atolli zitta
site.it ci ho ripensato dopo il
copyright è una cattiva persona
quindi niente thriller di michael j
vabbè tanto la sapete no c'è un topo
enorme però fa niente
dov'è che stiamo andando qua
salve oddio non scherzavo spegne
perfetto che è sta roba qua oh mio dio
osserva allora sicuramente devo
attivarlo sicuro perché se non lo attivo
sicuramente diranno mi si apre qualcosa
quindi lo attivo però non mi devo farne
anche vedere mamma mia ganz che la
guerra dei mondi cos'è sta roba
ocio la madonna mi ha preso
istantaneamente ma sono morto non è non
è così facile giu la leva devo stare
attenti gioco quel casino devi stare
veramente attento velocissimo
velocissimo velocissimo l'effetto con
rialza è la madonna quanto tempo
forse devo andare via alzarla prima e
poi dare corrente giusto perché se non
ce la faccio una faccia in tempo la lava
dolino alzo torna indietro e faccio sta
roba che ma le scosse elettriche
mancava solo questo guarda alta ecco ma
posso faccio casino di nuovo
ok
corro ok perfetto ragazzi sono stato
bravissimo
sicuramente c'era morto un miliardo di
volte ma ora va allora io finisco raga
sono carico carico a molla
cioè lui e meno carico nel senso che si
è preso la scarica elettrica però tra
l'altro ragazzi oggi c'è un principio di
febbre cioè la febbre a 37 e mezzo non
so se si vede se mi vedete un po strano
un poco pino pupino un po cupido è
perché c'è un pochettino di febbre arco
demonio to sorella morta attirata ecco
[Musica]
grazie browser
caustico il devo anche cantare che sono
funzionate il e in questione ma stringe
ma cos'è fai la giravolta falla un'altra
volta cos'è
a quelli che stanno nel caso devono
saltare va bene e quindi la ci guardano
oddio sono come quelli rica della casa
di cappella rapina la zecca ma per quale
motivo e wang yu jie poi c'è uno che ha
un bambino in mano tra l'altro c'è
proprio sono una cricca ma poi non mi
vedono chio la maglia rossa e tutti gli
altri non c'hanno la maglia rossa di
oraria quanto e michael jackson stamani
plcm che stia facendo tutto sto casino a
mi sono dimenticato di girarmi che pirla
pensavo non sarà col jazz e nessuno no
che palle
cioè proprio un casinò sta roba ci
sembra io gliene durante ecco sono le
mie lezioni di educazione fisica non so
se avete presente così uguale poi
dall'altro c'è un rumore ti mette un
ansia
porca vacca difficilissimo fatto il tipo
mi hanno beccato il tipo continuano a
dar avanti tranquillo come se niente
fosse
ora che è difficile sta parte non vorrei
di una cagata ma fare quello che fanno
loro esattamente un casino
chissà quale la trama visto fottutissimo
gioco ragazzi ti giuro che come lo
facebook.com sono fuori e sono fuori un
workshop ragazzi non posso leggere
scusate io sono un momento difficile
porco il demonio morto schifoso cane
addio
vorrei così fa sembra una cagata ma mi
confondo
saltato molto prima chissenefrega
quanta droga si è preso il creatore di
soggiorno c'è veramente ma qualcosa per
pensa sta roba
se stai male ok le sue girare
mamma mia la precisione signori
millimetrico ok
vorremmo perciò teoricamente fatta la
smetti di seguirmi basta ma come non ho
fatto niente ma non ho fatto niente ma
guarda non ho fatto niente ma tu sorella
morta
non ho fatto nulla se non avevo fatto
niente dai madonna
ora che è difficile non ho fatto
stavolta forse ero troppo avanti cos'è
che palle
madonna io mi sto impegnando ma neanche
quando so uno verso sono in forte anche
in finale
non fare nulla
[Musica]
6 basta basta
cosa sta succedendo lì ai cani madonna
che voglia di vivere
maledizione
mi sono scagliato addosso ho sbagliato
aveva fatto bene giusto vinto ce l'ho
fatta
ma dai con ricordi ce l'ho fatta pensavo
vino bio il cane pensavo io l'ho
sbagliato non ho sbagliato adesso ma tua
madre dai era giusto ce l'avevo fatta
sono stato bravissimo all'inizio perchè
ha detto mi devo correre o no mica
gaveau invece lo devo correre li
mortacci del mio cugino occhio se come
devo fare così guarda maturi di saltare
non salta fai il giro poi salgo tanto
riesce a salire e fare sempre giro bene
perfetto già apposto spingi spingi pg il
carrello significare ha poi ci sarà la
pausa pp dipende dagli infarti
ciao favi ciao ragazzi
non ho capito bene dove stiamo andando
adova vari show degli alberi è un po più
allegro di prima 6 propone schifo però
meglio di prima
ora teoricamente questo lo spingono non
so dove ma sicuramente da qualche parte
a ok anche io non capivo non stavo
capendo balance no
io spero di dio che questi www.apple.com
sono andati indietro tra l'altro come
questo e michael jackson moonwalk
nell'aria stavo dicendo spero iddio che
facciano il continuo veramente
incredibile suo gioco a vado ancora
avanti amido fermare giustamente vai
dovevo andare in tutto sto casino
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ragazzi non ho capito niente
la mia vita ancora cosa devo fare qua ma
come faccio a saltare su perché tu puoi
prendere a tua volta il controllo di
qualcosa di pazzo veramente a è un
controllo jackson ma come ma come è
possibile
c'è quindi un controllo per due un
casino due giorni fa il cervello sta
roba
quindi adesso sono qua schiaccia e mo
scendo col primo no sono sceso anche io
porca vacca morta e non è non è facile
ma si fa si fa ma edizione la vita vabbè
comunque fatemi sapere ragazzi se volete
più usati puro di ieri thank you reynald
madonna grazie rainaldo supergentile
grazie mille bechis thank you so much mi
piace anche tuo avatar
grazie paolo anche non troppo visto
thank you so much ragazzi cosa fare qua
si chiude la porta cosa devo fare
niente che me la devo studiare storia
che non ho capito cosa devo fare qua no
a una sega
forse devo metterlo qui in modo tale da
salire poi quando qua
scendo poi lo riprendo e vado con lucca
e mamma mia che questa era veramente
ragazza in un casinò questa sì però devo
spingere sempre questa è la vera mente
un casino
ci ho messo un'ora e mezza a capirla da
quanto è fatta bene lamentazioni sta
roba
c'è gente occhio
c'è gente la leva tira la leva tira leva
bravissimo ok alcuno si è spaventato
adesso mi hanno visto ciao ragazzi
chiamati i soccorsi
so che la vedo difficile per voi adesso
scendo so che non vorreste ma adesso
scendo ciao me la sono presa proprio
intercooler volevo fare il figo questa
faccia qua invece no campione la faccia
di una faccia di culo pontefice volevo
fare il figo niente li facciamo quello
che loro non si accorgono di niente e
poi quando tiro in cosa sicura come si
allarmano gli succede qua c'è un tizio
lassù a wired.com maps
benvenuta elisabetta rollo thank you
dopo lei giochiamo a league of legends
ragazzi non gioco a league of legends da
quando avevo 16 anni immagino neo 24 che
fa a dover spingere sto coso è una
zattera strano se si se uscisse il
capitolo ii legio che resti ma adesso
subito subito non finirei mai st live
praticamente magari bello però che c'è
un sacco di acqua in giro qua
prettamente a caso sono zuppo
dall'inizio alla fine
vestiti fradici ma chi se ne frega roba
che se fossi io veramente cioè la
polmonite tempo cinque minuti però ok
dov'è che sono finito qua e la madonna
urca vacca si è aperto
non ho capito ma ci sono dei tassi
devo giocare con l'acqua mannaia va bene
schiaccia ha quindi in base al tasso che
schiacciò si riempie da parte si toglie
l'altro che come minimo c'è un corso
dove galleggiare almeno questa una
botola che mi riporta dentro perfetto
devo capire un attimo sicuramente c'è un
corso dove galleggiare tipo la zattera
di prima a vediamo chi è ok devo portare
una roba qua sopra va bene e cosa che
porto
immagino che debba entrare dentro
entriamo mai non ho ben capito cosa deve
portarci dentro
è un bene che io mi ricordi le cose sono
serve troppo easing cioè boh
ah sì aperta a me ronco ho capito non
avevo visto c'era una porta lì sorry
quindi la prossima roba ciao nitro ci ho
messo un'ora leggere il nome perché devo
fare casino per guardare la mia mente
sta in questo modo ci sono i criceti che
lavorano non me lo so spiegare ma è così
ma fa col demonio chissà chi si fa sta
roba
ah ho capito devo schiacciarlo andando
che ho capito non schiacciarlo andando
sott'acqua scommettere così esatto
rossi chiude orc a ecco che è ora
giustamente migliaia roba per
galleggiare che è una valigia la valigia
di news cam under giocato chi stava
schiacciando tantissimo portato f c'è
una fisica perfetta soggiorno fi angelo
state angelov def in video
alex sa che cos'è angel of death angel
of death è un brano musicale del gruppo
musicale statunitense se lei è prima
traccia del terzo album in studio
raining blood pubblicato il 7 ottobre
1986 dalla del gene la canzone e loda a
causa del controverso testo che descrive
gli esperimenti chirurgici del dottor
josef mengele sui pazienti cade nel
campo di concentramento di auschwitz
durante la seconda guerra mondiale e la
trama di questo gioco lo farei
cara rita però non so suonare e cantare
grazie alla fiducia grazie rinaldo e ti
sei abbonato avevo visto perfetto
non è vero sono stupido dio
madonna ora la gente avanti porca vacca
la donna ha rischiato
se come devo fare step ma dai
maledizione alla vita eterna che pirla
io volevo fare pure il figo di non
morire cina anche una volta invece no ma
anna e me lo sono meritato
lo ricordi limbo e va bene non tutto ma
poi limbo e meno meno ti rimane di meno
limbo secondo me questo è proprio fatto
in modo che ti rimanga di più non so
come spiegare questa cosa
john ok stavolta ce l'ho fatta ma perché
l'ombra si muove pure giustamente
proprio ne hanno fatto perfetto per la
perfezione fatta gioco perfetto
vai limite ci arrivo non è vero
do per un nulla ci sono arrivato per un
millimetro facciamo due giri poi c'è un
primo
c'è proprio una malattia c'è mamma mia
il casinò sta roba proprio non mi
ricordavo gira gira gira adesso faccio
un altro giro in più per sicurezza
mamma mia sono rischiato
no a posto ciao ragazzi un attimo che
arrivò raga che sono in un momento
difficile sono un momento difficile un
secondo
minchia la botola meno male che ci
sostituti in alto sono come vasta sega
bello il treno bello allegro vai vai a
boss
mammamia l'ansia che è successo
scusatemi non ho visto che alexala
ricchi grazie christine nella trama
l'inside alexa alexa.com i qual è la
trama di inside non ne sono sicura
ma se ti va di provare qualcosa di nuovo
a un husky che si chiama su un
collettore potrebbe interessarti vuoi
provarla no io non so ogni volta che
chiedo qualcosa l'alexa mi verrebbe da
restituirla da amazon cioè ve lo giuro
non c'è stata una volta che mi è stata
utile
alexa mi dici la trama di inside gioco
indie non ne sono sicura allora ti va di
provare taci non ne sono sicuro sì ma se
vi va di pagare qualcosa di nullità vita
basta
la tratta male perché non sanno
rispondere non pagata non funziona cosa
vuoi 30 euro non va l'unico non averla
presa in scontro tra l'altro sono io
tutti tutti hanno pagato un centesimo e
mezzo io 39 29 onde ancora basta
steaming ieri cani te lo fa qua sicuro
c'è qualcosa devo prendere qua sotto mi
ci gioco quello che volete mi ci gioco
qualsiasi cosa qualsiasi questo barile
no c'è un tubo un tubo prendo il tubo
sicuro c'è qualcosa sotto sicuro
no vabbè io volevo fare il figo invece
avete aspettato niente non solo non è un
tubo messo lì per caso
intanto questo faceva veramente il
respiro più stupido del mondo dura un
secondo
che palle ho pure che cane delle palle
minchia
madonna ragazze ansia ma a testa di cane
madama guarda ma posso mai vivere una
vita così io cioè il cane pure
sott'acqua mi saranno faccio risucchiare
dal tubo di qua non ci tieni sotto è
cagasotto sono venuto io toto la mamma
mia mamma mia ragazzi difficilissimo
devo sicuramente fare il giro perché il
cane troppo veloce però non ho capito
come ma poi d'altro e sempre è sempre lo
stesso cane di prima che i cani che si
buttano addirittura in acqua mi chiami
mancava piuttosto che non prendermi ho
le palle giu ciao ciao ciao ciao bestia
maledetta vai let's go
corri corri corri a gesù a posto niente
va bene va bene
vabbè cocoricò riquadri minchia no ma è
impossibile
dio ma dai maracaibo
basta poi magari da sti cani andate a
cagare nel giardino fastidio ma manco ma
non posso far fuori ma vi rendete conto
di quanto dovrei metterci per terapia va
avanti e indietro qua un altro sorella
canina forse se mia vantaggio nel mentre
che ancora non sono arrivati
no no scherzavo scherzando scherzando
scherzavo scherzava scherzava senza
figli qua qua
minchia celebre niente a una trave alla
volta devo fare dopodomani entro lo
sapete
nicchia pensate che che fa stimare che
sono stupidi sti canio
che palle
sono passato vai vai perfetto gioca
tanto ci passano benissimo provenienti
ce l'ho fatta un'ora e mezza di cani va
bene oddio
dov'è che siamo qua
salve
minchia sotto ma già minchia sottomarino
occhio o chiocchio occhio occhio o
chiocchio chiocchio chi
ok
metteteli a parlare guardando non dalla
mia parte per favore ok agli foto il
sottomarino va bene grazie
miu miu
ho potuto il sottomarino di pgt a led
che mondo subacqueo bellissimo
bellissimo pausa pp e arrivo ragazzi un
secondo dato in un attimo arrivo
leggo arrivo
lo sci
il magico potere di queste cuffie
definirmi sotto la sedia non so come sia
possibile ogni qual volta faccio un
video da sette anni a questa parte la
sedia la cuffia di fitch e sotto la
sedia e non so il motivo sta bene sta
bene è solo un po piccolo nel senso che
non capisce un cazzo però va bene è
normale un cane piccolo quindi non ha
capito tante cose tipo che non mi deve
chiedere il cibo quando mangio però
penso che lo capirà mai è un bel camino
non c'e loquace l'hanno i miei va bene
scusate devo farvi di adesso ora
introdotto liquidi bene torniamo ai
liquidi ne ha un sacco tipo lui o la
madonna che cosa ho fatto anche alla
propulsione vero cosa propulsione
spaccatutto spaccatutto madonna ok
da allora dov'è che stiamo andando una
donna che [ __ ] l'amato minchia che anzi
a di vivere avrei stare qua sotto meno
male che non ci sono io in quel
sottomarino madonna che brutto è brutto
e fatto da dio però che brutta anzi mi
viene dovevo andare mi chiama che siano
sotto l'oceano guarda c'è un'apertura
vabbè
in corsa e si entra a posto non sono
anche dove stiamo andando però a madonna
ma che ansia mi chiama saremo otto
chilometri sotto il livello del mare
cioè se n'è sempre che siamo
ma perché l'altro scusatemi ma che è una
fabbrica sotterranea cioè subacquea ce
l'hanno riempito è un relitto di una
nave quello hanno capito oddio sbagliato
semplicemente un po ricaricarsi e poi
dalla bozza fissi ma mamma mia che mi
era brutto ha ricevuto a ma si può
uscire
no no stai dentro devo spaccare sto coso
ma siamo sicuri che si spacca
volevo spaccare tutto devo forse dovrei
spaccare aspetta no non si spacca a cc
devo passare io noto credo aspetta
perfetto mediche ogni tanto non sono
stupido atlantide inside
no no ma penso sia una nave pure lì non
lo so fatemi domande non
con la madonna aiuto a devo arrampicarmi
ok
devo portare qualcosa per aprire quella
porta e riprendermi sottomarino ma non
ho ben capito che cosa teoricamente
prove non fatemi uscire niente alla
finestra grazie ecco minchia se l'ho
detto porca vacca morta aiuto sono vivo
come ma come come sono morto come
possibile cioè non mi ha toccato
teoricamente corrie minchia che anzi a
vivere
dio è la madonna che male ma fatto sì
stavolta sono morto così questa volta
sono morto si può aprire la botola
ributtarmi nella botola ma semplicemente
non mi devo far schiacciare un casino
sembra facile ma non lo è vabbè cori e
basta quando arrivi di arrivi
minchia smartphone apposta posta
sono vivo ma che ci faccio pasqua hanno
aperto semplicemente la porta pensavo mi
servisse a qualcosa
stasera dovrei mangiare pizza perché il
sushi l'ho già mangiato ieri ma
migliaccio di nuovo voglia di sushi io
faccio schifo nella mia vita
siamo ancora capi un mio dio pure siamo
po esagerati ni madonna mi sono
ricordato che cosa faceva nel mentre che
ci stavo sopra detto ah ok sto qua
che faccio un attacco ma dai che scherzo
i.de.a ma vedi che qua c'è qualcosa tipo
una roba da togliere però se mi serve
sottomarino ho capito devo fare un giro
immenso prove ovviamente non devo stare
attento a non cadere mai perché se cado
una mezza volta ci mette un'ora tornare
indietro non è così semplice
maroni che c'è qualcosa qua a destra che
non ho visto tipo
no c'è solo del filo spinato però vede
vedete che siamo tecnicamente fuori
quindi non siamo sottoterra
perché c'è l'erba quindi vai
no ho sbagliato che culo l'ho ripresa
subito
bono dei tweets
non so neanche cosa mi è servito ma va
bene schiaccio ho riaperto la porta di
prima il mio sottomarino bellissimo
vamonos allora teoricamente adesso lo
sto coso lo prendo ora per i o no già
capirla 18
scusami c'è chi c'era un mostro
sottomarino melo sul corto ma era una
bambina sottomarina vero o sbaglio io
perfetto
15 nodi è una bottiglia di rum
mamma mia che bello far posto
siccome siamo wired.com più o meno però
mi ricordo bene mi è venuto amico mio
che devo fare qua
ho saltato senza un motivo in realtà
perché non mi ricordo cosa devo fare
[Musica]
facciamo allora che cosa rosso mi sa che
potevo schiacciare per far defluire
l'acqua può essere
esatto vai vai con uno ben capito il
senso
mi sa che dovevo già star e di là con
questo minchia ricordarsi o mi sa che
dovevo già stare dirà con questo non ha
senso comprare questa cosa quindi
schiaccia ok ok google chrome madonna
che dettagli che già ora me ne vado a
piedi di là giusto così sta portati apre
io continuo perfetto era molto più di
quanto pensassi
claque
ma rifarei anche i rimborsi però non
adesso c'è senso analisti
sto periodo perché ho fatto troppo poco
tempo fa simbolo fatto ne ha una ma
forse nemmeno un annetto fa non sia un
annetto e passato però troppo poco
inside sono passati potrà quasi non lo
so
queste che dopo che lo fate inside non
era 2000 secondo me era il 2017
sono passati due anni e mezzo da quando
ho fatto inside almeno salve eccolo però
dimenticato cioè viscusi mannaia mi sa
che non devo farmi toccare con la luce
vedi che ce la sto mostro bambina me lo
ricordavo io aiuto madonna quando per
quanto corre veloce e devo puntare la
roba addosso perché se non mi entra cosa
che fa mi entra nel sottomarino smettila
vai a casa tua
minchia ma non si passa di aiuto allo
sfondare il soffitto
smettila no no non lo si è sfondato orco
demoni minchia via craccato il vetro
mammamia bruttissimo e cosa che ha fatto
ma preso ma così è stato
chi è questa e un nostro sottomarino
orribile vai via
madonna raga non me lo ricordavo così
krypi
bene e ho capito però devo spaccarlo ho
capito me lo fate sparire come faccia a
faccia parte maledizione o mi levo dal
sottomarino non posso mica st barth e
difficilissima c'è una sedia tra l'altro
va bene
allora devo capire come fare sta roba
aspetta boh gioca a perché non potevo
spaccarla in tempo sta roba
ok che non ci sarei mai arrivato meno
male che l'ho visto il tempo ci sono
ce l'abbiamo fatta dopo chilometri e
chilometri sottomarino giunge a riva
teoricamente la parte col sottomarino è
finita ragazzi teoricamente adesso poi
non mi ricordo però ce l'abbiamo fatta
ma kick ass c'è una porta porta enorme
giorno saremo al 70 per cento immagini
dei giovani proprio il caput vacca e
vabbè mi è andata ancora bene
salve buongiorno era da un po che non
comandavo gente mi date una mano ad
aprile vi darà mano ma fa niente fai
quello che vuoi
mi sa che devo mandare gente propri
portali dove che siamo finiti tipo
un'altra fab atom che posto giga
che figata non ricordavo che ha fatto
bene suo gioco ma non così bene perché
ogni volta lamentazione ti sorprende
sempre questo bello energia
ciò un pochettino di febbre non solo del
singolo dottore mi dà fastidio
la febbre da fastidio è proprio
fastidiosa perché esiste ciao 19 24 la
rinascita turco demonio 18 a quanta
gente sta sulla piattaforma minchia 18
te ne devo portare sei scemo ma che
nessun rumore gola
chi è che il mona che sbatte la porta le
orlando
c'è uno che sbatte la porta libro è un
gigante dove trovare 18 persone per
aprire la porta ottimo faccio spero che
unico uno di quelli sono io
minchia dove sto andando aiuto scherzava
non così tanto allora mi servono 18
persone
venite per favore tutti mi dispiace
farvi per la febbre nella tranquilla
succede altro perché in casa mia c'è
l'aria condizionata a palla è fuori fa
caldo bestia quindi mi sono veramente
spaccato sì però io che ho bisogno di
gente che mi dia una mano sono cugat
è che il mondo è per te che ti che va
posta
guarda che si sente le botte si sentono
anche qua sotto ti pare ma chi è
minchia pure non aspetta fammi capire ma
non c'è gente in sto posto cioè non so
se avete capito come faccio a eccoli
perfetto scherzavo ci sono invece
scendere signori mi serve vi servite
tantissimo tratta
molti di voi in realtà mi date una mano
per favore dell'acqua minchia st parte
la vedo difficile lo so già pure
minchia lo que sto andando chi è
ma la donna cosa mi significa o che
possono portare arrampicarmi perfetto
non avevo capito sorry non servì come
sto facendo ora vado avanti perché
immagino che io debba andare di qua ma
non so bene cosa sto facendo sincero io
la guarderei subito una serie tv stoffa
c'è solo su inside subito proprio
neanche a chiedermelo
e veramente figo c'è questa atmosfera e
fighissima mi fa impazzire anche in dark
tipo di netflix mi fa impazzire sosta
c'è questa atmosfera molto tripi che mi
ph giù le mani pervertito a mi seguono a
minchia però non fanno tutto quello che
faccio io mi seguono sia un puro e
wireless ma che figo beh ragazzi allora
devo rifiutare un po di gente venite con
me c'è in realtà mi servirebbero molto
più di dibo york caput vacca aspettate
c'è un baratro devo portarlo ascensore
fatemi salire per cortesia tiramisù
bravo bravi bravi maledizione pelati
bravissimi i miei pelati vi chiameremo
così pelati state fermi fermi che cadete
giu fermi fermi state fermi fermi
statevi immobili fermi che cade giù
porco demonio come faccio a farli star
fermi o teste di mini aggrappatevi alla
sace non come alto league il casco togli
telo quesito togli te l'ho tolto dalla
testa solito e cadono e va perciò vostra
sorella infame toccati a non cadono ok
si fermano prima erano un po
intelligenti ne dite
bravi aiutatemi a madonna che ansia però
se però mi fissate così che brutta
bruttissima a me ne servono allora 12345
me ne mancano quanti ce ne servivano 18
17 per come lo sono io quindi me ne
mancano 12 vendite di qua i pelati
fantastici come si chiamano pelati
brothers
ciao chiara grazie mille un bacino di
dei pelati per como novara riguarda li
guardi come come li brilla la capoccia
al sole guarda guarda ma gunnes che
gioia credo che sta roba debba stare qua
perché se non avrebbe senso quel buco
però non ho ben capito cosa mi porta
quindi portami grazie la pelata mania
che arriva a devo cadere sul cosa
aspetta no
si fa
devo andare di là quindi immagino che io
debba saltare qua sopra e poi loro mi
spingono giusto cioè credo aia puttan
tua sorella
ma perché avete spinto il comma 7
stupidi ma ve ne dovete stare se non vi
dico allora ho capito che il vostro
cervello è occupato a capire che siete
pelati però non dovete fare le cose di
testa vostra fatto di testa mia se io
non vi dico di spingere 1 spingete che
poi fatto un casino state fermi con le
mani
mettetevele nel deretano per favore e la
famiglia bisio saluto al claudione che
ci segue tutti i giorni grazie claudio
digis bisogno di capelli o domani me li
taglio vedendo un po ciao claudio un
bacio orali che board ma non mi però non
dovete spingere quando decidete voi che
sono un casino è possibile dove che sto
andando in tutto sto casino
c'è una trave togli la mano mi arrampico
ok non sono anche dove sto andando però
del baby e ben di and hate machine devo
portarlo dove riportarli cioè devo
finirlo senza problemi basta la vita
sempre dove c'è gente me ne servono 12
togli che facciamo trovare mi scusi
sparami spara mir
ma dai ma che
veramente c'è una propulsione di un
gatto morto a perché era sotto terra ok
quindi chrome non mi stavo pensando le
mani già fatta ciao gente
seguitemi che qualcosa in testa io
parlai è bello sono tre ne manca 9
sentite one direction segua perfetto
dell'inizio milan vincendo benvenuto
le manca 9 spero di trovarli tutti di
sopra perché sono un casino ciao ciao
pelati vi presento altri pelati la
pelato mania prosegue ma se io li porto
nel punto dove devono stare fermi san
fermino un workshop way con benvenuti
ragazzi piano 3
ma io andrei direttamente a quello sopra
pure sì però ragazzino mi fissate per
favore che un'ansia marche vacanza
mamma mia non mi toccate
ci stavamo divertendo i pelati sono
simpatici comunque non so cosa c'è gente
aiutatevi aprire no minchia dovuta riggi
spingente spingete ma si va a fan gulas
ore da apposta qualcuno si può a
suicidare prego ne va anche a nove
quelli erano 3 1 2 o 3 anni corde poi ce
n'era uno all'inizio teoricamente
dovremmo quasi esserci ai ragazzi
teoricamente vediamo cosa ci va a destra
figurati se non c'era qualcosa
minchia allora ragazze mi spinge tema le
vi ammazzo grazie state lista degli
stati che cade te è un casino
salve ho bisogno di lei venga che cazzo
cos'è che stai vedendo che ho bisogno di
vedere anch'io no e curiosità la mia
cos'è che celi dietro che faccia di chi
è che fa che cazzo di rumore lì mi
prendeva il naso allora amici vi regalo
un amico a posto grazie gentili gentili
volete buttarvi anche voi che divertente
no
i pelati hanno bisogno i tuoi capelli e
vero ce n'è un po per tutti siamo
123456789 più quello che è caduto 10 10
ne mancano 8 che mi tiene mancano otto
ragazzi questi sono morti no posto 123
quindi 13 ne mancano 50 fiom con 5 un
casino benvenuto amico mio
dovete essere in 56 da solo te ne stai
lì quanti siete a dove di qua uno con
nemmeno mancano 4
eccoli non sono due quelli put barca
anche qua lasciami non sono tre minchia
ne manca uno raga amaolo era già lì che
aspetta
minchia che testata codato mi dispiace
uno era già lì se ci pensate era davanti
allo schermo quindi le basta che ci vado
vicino e lo attira teoricamente quindi
ce l'abbiamo tutti
minchia che botte ragazzi domani mal di
schiena lo sentite
mamma mia se ce l'ho fatta
ciao a milano sono in quattro loro
direttamente a posto
camo
ma ti contiamo faceva contro c'è una
pronta anzi non cantiamo quattro pirati
sul mar dei sargassi sopra una zattera
fatta di assi vanno remando dicono loro
fa ragazzi avete mai giocato con due tre
stella vi girate vince mi ci giriamo e
voi vi fermate uno due tre stella
no non funziona avete sete capaci non
siete capaci non siete capaci
kilometrico i pelati mi chiamo mio
raduno sono 1 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
qui 16 17 io sono 18 circa un mese lotti
19 pro e quel morto lì al morto lo
trascino dentro venite state la state lì
dentro per cortesia
mancano 2 1 e 2 no apri la porta
chi è che fa il casinò li chiede il mola
che sbatte le porte qua dietro questo
casino un [ __ ] che è successo michele
bus degli impatti tremendo minchiam onda
d'urto assurda
cos'è
apache dukas minchia che onde d'urto a
me corri stare attento a non non
beccarmi in onda tutte in faccia
minchia no ragazzi in ansia stanno
arrivando dei missili cos'è a minchiate
mamma mia che ansia rivivere l'amato ci
ho provato c'ero quasi madonna di euro
ma che è sta roba mai corre veloce
scherzavo c'è veramente devo fare una
devo essere di una precisione
millimetrica farlo vedere
ok
minchia che mi chiama mamma se mi sono
salvato nella maniera più assurda vai a
posto bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye vanno così sta roba
tra l'altro vi giuro ragazzi non
capiscono mi ricordo non mi ricordo
neanche
la minchia devo fare bene
speriamo speriamo l'apparato che culo
bravissimo pedalate il gusto
concentrando ok
teoricamente c'è da rifare
perfetto stato bravissimo
non ho letto adesso poi leggo
scusate ragazzi ma un momento difficile
la mia vita questo capitolo
madonna se mi sono salvato ce l'ho fatta
ci ho messo un'ora e mezza ma porca
vacca se mi sono salvato è stato un
casino ma di un difficile
minchia io vi giuro grazia un'ansia è
stata un'ansia un'ansia incredibile
grazie gianmarco grazie mille
mi sono spaccato ma se quello che
riprendono le acque scelta di me stesso
a
così d'amblè
non sei consapevole alessandro di aver
sterminato i fegatini un sacco di haters
questa roba è
si passa united killer cos'è che è
successo grazie ma nel non può che tanto
faccio ducazzi non so che dire
minchia
mi scusi le pongo una domanda ma manco
mai e niente proprio così senza magonza
volee di di non lo so un saloon qualcosa
non senso non salutano ci pensa una roba
più adeguata insomma così d'amblè
proprio grazie
minchia 6 smart key esagerate però
grazie mazza sul conte grazzini centro
con tempera carità di dio un po di
magari un caffè me lo prendo però anche
500mila per il pro grazie sei molto
troppo troppo troppo esagerato pro
grazie alessandra sini stato super gt
madonna thank you
un bacino molto gentile davvero grazie
cioè teschi in una roba che magari non
so una domanda però grazie grazie grazie
lo stesso qui sono mi ha spiazzato mi
aspetto soprattutto perché è stato un
momento in cui ho dovuto schivare rob è
quindi già la mia mente era flebile
flebile alex sa cosa vuol dire flebile
labile significa di suono voce fievole
sommessa come per altri significati
chiedimi altre definizioni percebile
forse non c'entrava una sega questo
aggettivo c'entra niente è veramente un
po leggera
intenzione quindi non ho saputo reagire
insomma ci ho messo un po a comprendere
insomma le grazie all'ex a lungo mi
compro nelle alex che funzionano
facciamo così no grazie sono proprio la
parte di scherzi a parte gli scherzi
no io ho bisogno a parte tutto ho
bisogno di una pausa perché mazza
spaccato gullo bene i conti continuiamo
continuiamo grazie ad esse da alessandro
scusami pure storpiato il nome manu e
manco leggere ma o degli occhiali che
non già non servano alla sega manco
leggere grazie mille
è come la franzoni secondo meno te
l'aspetti insomma
madonna era vediamo cos'è sta roba qua
una faccenda veramente difficile fa
madonna si vice taiga sale in fila stimi
sì ma non ho capito poi cos'è e sono
missili cos'è in casa non riesco ad
arrivare al punto dove arrivano sti
cosimi armi giuro mi mi girano le palle
all'acqua funziona perché c'è il coso
che lo tiene ma quella botta talmente
forte da spazzati completamente via ma
ti pare
google chrome nel minuto pettirosso
ecuador e
[Musica]
ma dai
no dio dio perché perché sono stupido no
ho sbagliato apposta
ok
vado a fare un casino
perfetto minchia se devi correre se de
vico allora chiederci quali vettura
manca la luce c'è problema incredibile
si arrivò alla fine del gioco è ancora
non trovo chi è che miss fare i missili
guarda ritiro un pugno pago la testa
cioè non ce la posso fare è incredibile
no no no no
sbagliato non volevo fare così vabbè non
volevo chiudermi in un ascensore cioè
l'ultima cosa che avrei voluto fare però
ho sbagliato no
minchia vabbè se di temi sesto gioco non
è fatto la perfezione è incredibile
gioco incredibile
esci e ci sono morto se non esci sto
pagando
sto affogando a fuoco maledizione
dai dai vedere del resto fuga moio non
sono morto
minchia sono figo per me ragazzi è un
costante una costante sopravvivenza sto
gioco c'e veramente un'ansia che non
finisce mai dall'inizio alla fine
non ti schiacciare non ti schiacciare
uniti ok oddio no una porta mezza aperta
non mi piace perché o escono cani è
riuscito nessuno che sta a cavallo
siamo andati un bel po avanti e ragga
mamma mia
siamo andati veramente un sacco avanti
dio mio dovrebbe da quant'è che sono in
live un'oretta e 45 minuti quasi 2
secondo me secondo me siamo quasi sulla
fine però non ne sono sicuro tac allora
qua mi stai veramente sfidando a cercare
di capire cosa come funzioni la vita ma
potevo fare direttamente che saltava su
quello però a 12
google chrome effetto credo di aver
fatto giusto penoso welcome ragazzi
benvenuti nel udine la cir ma perfetto
che proprio lui no no minchia a non mi
stai morte morta cioè morta nel senso è
dormiente
ok non mi sono cagato addosso
scusate non la tocco
no non ci credo ma per cosa vuole da me
cos'è che vuoi dalla mia vita spiega mi
devo andare avanti
lo spero di riuscire a fare ce l'ho
fatta minchia raga ma che a me non ha un
gioco non è un attimo di tre di tregua
ma neanche uno proprio incredibile
aprile
non ho capito cosa devo fare di quella
esalta a dovevo prendermi lo slancio per
entrare nella porta prima che la tipa mi
prendesse se magari adesso chi la porta
prima che mi ammazza non ci la porta ce
l'ho fatta incredibile ma cosa vuoi cosa
vuoi dalla mia vita sparisci
ok
minchia sta diventando un casino ma
finisce male ve lo dico io stato fare
qui
si chiedeva aiuto
non ho capito no mi prende mi
prenderebbero sbagliato ok ma cos'è e
cosa mi mangia non capisco gli ammazza
in che modo non si capisce highway credo
di dover fare dietrofront per poterla
fregare senza ritornare tutti indietro
ma non so dove cioè non ho capito dove
dovrei arrivare così d'acqua faccio
usino schiaccio e torno indietro modo
che lei non mi prenda però non capito il
senso e modo vallo che ci faccio qui
e adesso torno indietro ma dove chimiche
evidentemente evidentemente infatti non
ha capito
quando non manco toccato l'acqua proprio
un fenomeno ma dove vado a cosa mi serve
questa cosa
eccola
dai
e adesso non siamo esattamente come
prima cosa vista e vita sta cagata
che vi giuro sta partendo una pista
ma forse aspetta forse ce l'ho ce l'ho
ce l'ho ce l'ho capito credo almeno
siccome è sta roba tocca l'acqua devo
pescarlo a pescarlo non so cosa devo
fare
se io rimango inzuppato nell'acqua così
no no no no no ho sbagliato ma mai a me
9 tipo così no vado proprio a pendoli
penso lawzi è però ma che cosa serve
quello che non capisco che cosa serve
forse ci sono forze non è detto però può
essere
quindi lo attirata lontano e adesso
possa andare nell'altra porta credo
posso
dio
mamma mia mamma mia è stato
difficilissimo giu non capivo non capivo
c'è proprio una roba millimetrica
non capivo che culo a posto
ecco non ci sono più i missili almeno
c'è questa buona notizia
la cassaforte la rapina alla zecca no ma
basta che palle fatti una vita
mamma mia oh niente la vita non esiste
sua viceversa addio
google chrome minchia vi giuro io questa
chiave l'ammazzo l'ammazzo l'ammazzo che
fastidio benvenuto un cane che mangia
boldi
ciao ma mi sa che dovevo aprire e poi
tornare su giusto un casino
torna su torna su per un software non si
torna su minchia quanto rischiato ero
più morto è vivo
ok
let's go proprio lui
mamma mia ragazzi le parti in acqua sono
di un difficile siamo più o meno il
sottomarino e ho perso le visivamente
immagino proprio c'è verso vabbè due ore
di live quasi ci siamo
orca mi sono pagato
no no no e allora guardia che ha non mi
sa che dobbiamo andare così stavolta
stavolta mi doveva prendere sul serio ma
lame pervertita e muoiono respiro
voglio per forza fatto io posso
dimenarmi ma non serve a niente
cosa che sta facendo
quindi cosa mi fa e cosa fa adesso
spiega mi porti negli inferi st bambina
maledetta
all sono diventato pelato bravo nulla
allora vieni far parte della mia ciurma
debellato
cos'è sta roba new york chrome grazie
fabio benvenuti nella cricca dei pelati
mi ha mollato qui tutto sto casino per
mollarmi allora cosa vuoi della mia vita
aia non ha mai staccato il coso ma [ __ ]
sono morto non respiro sott'acqua sono
un essere umano io non come quel mostro
lì
chi sa quanto è profondo sul posto
questa roba
c'è un cavallo sono vivo bene il respiro
lo lasciamo agli esseri umani normali
io no non sono motivi respirare
sott'acqua anche le mille volte che mi
aveva preso prima no grazie pesci grazie
per avermi dato le vostre branchie così
c'è un cavo che va finì lì dentro non ho
mai capito dove vado posso tornare tutto
su con la tanto respiro a ruba
sott'acqua attenzione tra l'altro sta
questura mi sembra talmente grosso
l'unica roba che miri più grossa di
questo che creò presente tipo la porta
al 2
cosa che si facciano esperimenti ma
mamma mia come dovrà rifinirlo per
leggere le teorie giuro che bella per i
pesci e alla fine sono ha finito e
respiro sott'acqua giusto così
madonna c'è la mia io piuttosto sparami
mi ammazzerebbe dove fare quello che sta
facendo il suo bambino
e mia zia quando rotta
occhio che per un attimo rischiato di
esserci di finirci dentro
tira no no no no no no no no ho capito
troppo tardi quello che stava succedendo
a posto corri corri corri corri corri e
lì mi attacco a sti cosi capito
tutta roba che funziona a intermittenza
senza un motivo perché è un motivo non
c'è in tutto questo
minchia che rischio madonna
veroli è ok dove stiamo andando a finire
belli i topi comunque fa piacere sono
l'unica persona man toccato persone
ops
ok
che le quando devo girare la manovella e
ci sono sti cosi
e allora tua madre è proprio brutta una
forte chiaro ogni volta ci sono emanuele
cisi wharol com
mi sa che devo aspettare che va di là
perché paradossalmente ci mette di meno
che madonna ha mai ronco
ok mi sono salvato il culo dai e perché
io nella vita non sto zitto perché
qualcuno lo spiega un casino no dio è
difficile sto gioco che per
intellettuali o ci sono gli occhiali
degli intellettuali e rosso con gli
occhiali ragazzi non sembrano tipo di
oggi ho vinto 30 euro alle macchine 130
martin garics più o meno ma aspetto a
gira gira gira gira gira gira gira che
la vita a un casino
ok
ma ci devo salire proprio sopra orco
demonio
c'è una piazza io ci devo salire sopra
per poi salire sopra di nuovo no lì mi
serve che scenda ok perfetto
ok hai dett minchia devo centrare il
buco
va bene a me lo faccio ripetere pesci
salve dove ci siete voi io respiro
quindi no problem qualcuno di voi sa
perché respiro sott'acqua ti servirebbe
saperlo perché son curioso ma c'è un
buco non posso entrare
scusate la gara ma mi sa che qua si
arriva semplicemente permettere a tutti
dalla caduta ma in realtà deve uscire ok
ma un e quei casi dove tengono 13 e 11
di santini non lo sa ormai mikako
addosso per qualsiasi luce ragazzi anche
la cos'è sta roba capisce l'acqua sul
soffitto
scusatemi no ecco quest'anno ma
ricordato come questa non l'ho capita
neanche orco demonio tutto bene c'è
dell'acqua sul soffitto come se niente
fosse
ma vedi che poteva aprirlo quelli in
quel coso lì sapevo
devo fare un giro della madonna prova
bene www.ef.com ciao thunder
benvenuto
sai che sono sti cosi raga ma questa
cosa proprio non me la ricordo
non me la ricordo per niente giuro
google chrome andare di qua ok ben di
dio ti ho filippo benvenuto
new york com la madonna un casino grazie
raga non ho capito sincero sai che
questo non l'ho capita vv e wroclaw non
devo fare la voce un caso che ho chiuso
ma non ho neanche capito perché forse
perché devo far arrivare l'acqua di
sotto
me lo spiegate questa ragazza che vi
giuro non ho capito cosa devo fare
google chrome e devo andare devo farmi
schiacciare l'ho vista fare per qualche
strano motivo mi sa che non è così
ma poi mi sono spostato giustamente
vabbè ma qua non ci sono già passato
prima come giustamente capirla allora
allora c'è qualcosa di qua a sinistra no
e allora cosa devo fare non posso fare
niente
aiuto spiegatemi cosa devo fare
ditemelo pesci ti prego
giuro questa cosa non l'ho capita
ma non è che qui c'era qualcosa che non
ho preso
c'è un'altra strada e che ne so ave di
sori non avevo scoperto io sta roba
perfetto se schiacciano mi ammazzate vi
prego ok a questo lo devo portare in
giro addirittura a dopo spaccare
quell'affare no
ha forse devo dare una botta quando in
alto c'è da avere un tempismo
incredibile ok ma porca put vacca beh la
potente e si va e si va col mio nuovo
aggeggio qualche centrale cristiano
ronaldo bravissimo mi piace mi stava
pizzicando la faccia fortissimo però fa
niente e vedi che alla fine mi serviva
sta roba perché loriblu riporto su
quindi
a lo chiudo quando è chiaro o era molto
più facile di quanto pensassi bene
easy comunque sono due ore di gameplay
adesso quindi alla fine durato un po di
quello che pensavo
c'è un politico realtà penso che andiamo
per le 3 entro le 8 lo finisco blu penso
di sì
skype
ho capito cosa devo fare e veramente
difficile provo a tavola stortissimo
ce l'ho fatta oh mio dio
e vabbé sono sotto sono sopra non
capisco come poter definire questa cosa
sopra acqua non sott'acqua
ci sono sotto l'acqua ma di sopra non
capisco il senso com'è possibile
ho tolto delle cose che non dovrei
togliere però va bene tanto
questo è il nemico finale di metal slug
no facciamo qua deve entrare permesso
sono anche due posso salve sono anche
bene cosa stia succedendo nel dubbio
ma ci devo ritornare in quella stanza di
prima non è finita ok ma perché
veramente c'è gente buongiorno ragazzi
salve a tutti
devo capire cosa devo fare qua prendo
questo in prestito
scusate mi prendo è stata lì fermi
centin cambiata ma che diavolo di trama
cesto gioco giuro che quando lo finisco
leggo tutto tutto camere da wired.com
dell'astro fase ciao amico mio
via la gente a e amazon
posso solo col bambino in mano il
bambino tra l'altro avrà la mia età se
ti pare che la porta
chiudi quella porta va la giudico la
porta li chiudi a porto rico che
metodologia di sopravvivenza e di
nascondersi over the top prove
sono sotto l'acqua questo è sott'acqua
ma perché c'è un bambino li mi stanno
guardando
mi vedono fa niente fa niente
ma non se ne sono accorti che sto
facendo sta cosa
proveniente va bene
qui non se ne sono accorti che sta
abbassando alzando il livello dell'acqua
a caso così senza un motivo
ok
sai che è difficile capire cosa può fare
qua mi sa che cosa fare la mano devo
portare lì ho capito
google chrome e fai pensare
non è vero non ho capito
questo affare lo devo portato portare
questo di qua ma io no
collisione sarà sbattono la minchia
tanto ve ne frega
ok
ah ho capito ho capito ho capito under
un casino capito capito adesso ci ho
messo un ora a capirlo ma l'ho capito
devo prendere queste metterlo qua sicuro
no non devo usare la scatola per tenere
la porta aperta alla lega perché non ci
arrivo lì come la metto la scatola porta
impossibile però faccio questo
tac
perfetto scatola li porta aperta chiuso
adesso aperta adesso anche tensione a
mamma mia
la tattica
gol
tanto non si sentiva l'audio in quella
stanza proprio cell audio
posso mai non sono anche qui dove sto
andando gimenez ma ormai non sono anche
più cosa sto facendo della mia vita
un salve ancora sta gente
scusatemi ragazzi devo capire cosa posso
fare qua a picchia tutto bene che figata
porco demonio porco ma dai
maledizione chiavi su quello
vince poco un tizio di 18 non avevo
visto mai poi giù corri corri corri per
i primi a magath devo passare il livello
dell'acqua ottimo dove chi stiamo
andando
dio mio che difficoltà
ma dov'è nato il tipo di prima è
completamente scomparsa non tipo prima
che non c'è più ma cascano tutti e lo
sapevo scusate amici non volevo ha sede
a posto eseguite grazie mi fate andare
c'è uno che la testa staccata a una non
era proprio la testa ok bene allora mi
servirebbe che mi facesse arriva allora
facciamo così ci facciamo sto gioco io
vado alla leva e vi spingete c'è un tipo
morto per terra
va beh tu stai lì dai tiratemi su lily
sulla leva sulla leva ragazzi sulla leva
sulla leva madonna che mira brutta la
leva bravi bravi ok seguitemi ballast
ormai chi le cose le sole le so le vedo
le so
esperimenti dietro il vetro ma qua è
tutto un esperimento ragazzi comunque
mai inizio con risotto bellissimo
se non mi prendete vi ammazzo ammazzati
uguale però vabbè venite ciao
venite venite seguitemi tutti halloween
eh no no no no no no va bene fa niente
mi dispiace amici siete pazzi o così gli
succede lì c'è gente che ci va anch'io
voglio andar lì ma mi sa che doveva
andare dove sono visti dove siano
buttati quelli sai mi sa che era giusto
sono le sono dei sette sono le 723 più o
meno ma l'orario a ma l'orario è quello
del computer c'è ma è impossibile che
abbia azzeccato l'orario è veramente
l'orario è esattamente l'orario del
computer quello esattamente l'orario del
computer
com'è possibile minchia grazie ragazzi
non sarei morto io ve lo assicuro
come avete fatto a sopravvivere è un
chilometro di caduta
esattamente erano il computer assurdo
già su realtà è una cosa [ __ ] che non
c'è non so cosa mi sarei mai aspettato
in un gioco come inside e vorrei non
schiacciare i miei amici di sopra ma fa
niente
ragazzi scendete scendete si scende no
mente di qua dove stiamo andando
scendete tutti per favore ok non mi
credete addosso cavi c'è proprio all
amia la mia orda di zombie
personalizzata
let's go proprio
se però evitasse di di quali fissarmi
nel maine no non mi toccate non mi
toccate ho detto datemi una manina la
manina tutti
vai se ne ho fatta di strada dove la
signori io vi porto la libertà più o
meno dice uno che correrà sullo sfondo e
io sono qua con gli zombie
tiratevi su molto bene
rula la corrente del telefono appena
staccata ci è passata gente qui
ragazze schifo andiamo avanti
o
mi chiama dai viste le sedie assediare
ha deviato che è stata guarda posso
unirmi a voi fa niente se ci sono
porca vacca non me ne frega nulla massi
non me ne frega nulla guardiamo ma si
guarda te chiesto bambino e sono sono da
solo cosa stiamo guardando cosa che
guardiamo tutti che bello non ho mai
vista una roba così [ __ ] in tutta la mia
vita
giuro bellissimo energia è talmente
materica che anche questa fatta con
dipinto ad olio smalto energia non è che
cosa ci sto facendo qua però mi porto il
carrello fa
ma footing al real thank you
sono anche low cost cosa state guardando
che ci ama guardare quella programmiamo
noi io quelli guardano lì e io faccio
parkour giustamente ciao energia
l'energia è talmente materica
a baboola la vasca dove guardano tutti
ma che ci sta dentro il pesce rosso non
mi ricordo cosa c'è dentro la vasca
ragazzi vi giuro
questa cosa non me la ricordo giusto
problema non mi ricordo cosa c'è nella
vasca nicchia quelli che si gira e chi è
stato bocciato tutti affissa la vasca io
ne vado
come è giusto che sia ciao
se ci sto sopra giustamente che che apro
a poster
mi ricordo che ci devo entrare nella
vasca ma non mi dicono per quale sono
vivo motivo
minchia che ansia
ok
stiamo andando pian piano verso la vasca
però sono anche bene mykola che bene
cosa c'è dentro
ah ecco fantastico
tira ma io ci sono leve sono fa vigili
semplici sono leve io tiro 12
c'è chi te attenzione non togliere e io
e dopodiché c'è anche questo come caput
vacca io non so cosa sto facendo
fa niente ah ok ok ok
devo attivare in modo che che parta la
ventola e io poi riesco a essere
risucchiato nel tempo limite in cui si
chiude però non ho ben capito perché lo
dovevi fare per entrare nella vasca ma
perché dovrei entra nella vasca perché
sono così pazzo
90 signori per la papua nuova guinea
c'è un lodo a te piace il birillo è luca
quella che ci sono delle presine qua ti
piacciono queste presine tata tata tata
tata non lo faccio e se lo facessi e se
non lo facessi ma se lo facessi ma se
non lo facessi ma io lo facessi è stata
la festa caleno si stacca dai volo
stacca le cose non è che non lo facessi
o le polpette sono può fare a salve
c'è una roba qua stacco scossa va bene
c'è una palla di merd non cos'è sta roba
come sono persone c'è una palla di
persone no ma inglobato nuova inglobato
sono la palla questa roba che ero la
palla me lo ricordavo non ho ben capito
cosa devo fare
ragazzi avete presente che cosa succede
nei film horror
quando qualcuno si attacca le cose che
si sradica tutto
mi piace guardare cosa dal vetro ed e
via guarda dal vetro
mi dispiace giorno sono fatto di farina
e grande notte di studio in ottimo tool
che continui a sbattere sul vetro va
bene continua a parma
vado giù sono una palla giorno che cosa
pensi che mi fermi a me con software
chic mi fermi unitis tacco anche la
famiglia oltre che la porta
apri questa porta va la lurido pezzente
vieni qua ok quando sei andato tutto
schifoso sono una palla che è
incredibile ai ragazzi vede come andiamo
a conquistare il mondo venite la madonna
un fenomeno che lamento brutto magari ce
l'ha fatta a tirarmi su non credo che si
faccia forse sì vi spingete tantissimo
spingete spingete spingete grazie miei
amici sempre bello farsi degli amici
orco demonio quali peso eccessivo
va bene
ciao madonna
salve che è stata a guardare
ci sono io buongiorno e oggi è gratis la
visita tu sei morto mi fa piacere
salve vi date una mano a salire per
favore è successo
ciao marco grazie sentito non fatico a
leggere mai a chi sa che i capelli
bellissimi grazie sono i miei
so che fa strano ritrovare qualcosa per
salire tipo questo grazie ho staccato un
server del di facebook
è semplicemente l'azienda di facebook
mark zuckerberg stava fa esperimenti
ho trovato una donna ho trovato una
cassa guarda che tutti mi guardano gli
perché sanno che non posso muovermi
nello spazio ma solo avanti indietro
senti meglio appena diventano 3d cosa ti
faccio
porca vacca già fissate a buffon dalla
mensa è cosa che davano fagioli mamma
mia quanto vi ho fatto il culo
e pensare che stamattina era solo un
bambino come crescono in fretta e aprite
la porta nova niente a posto ho fatto io
cosa devo fare
ma lei e il direttore ma salve
buongiorno
guardi che cosa fanno i suoi esperimenti
ho creato una polpetta mistica ha visto
che bello ha impegni per oggi andiamo a
giocare a bowling le insegno come si fa
ragazzi sono stato troppo bravo l'ho
fatto scappare
fa niente io me ne vado peccato avrei
voluto ucciderlo non sapevo ci fosse la
possibilità di far scappare la gente
sdradica la porta c'è una gamba li ha
non posso sera dichiara porta deve
lanciare qualcosa league
spetta alla trave la trave premia tra le
boe sono ancora intelligente nonostante
io sia una palla in mutaforme
eccoci occhio a cava quanto faccio
schifo solo su google.com fornicazione
di una polpetta morta effettivamente
però lo sei
dice motivo c'è la prendi la misura tiro
su vabbè dai vulcani sì certo schiaccio
come se niente forse cani maledetti
ma che volete la mente ma che voi a cane
a pezze a mi sa che devo andare
devo prendere la trave e portarla lì da
maghetta buy
e cazzo da buy
ecco salita di salis ali veloci veloci
ed gol c'è gente che sta ancora correndo
per vedere cosa faccio ciao io non ho
paura di buttarmi da ormai e mibu tanto
qualsiasi punto mi butto sopravvivo al
massimo per di una gamba mano mille di
chi se ne frega che faccio qui prende la
rincorsa mi aprì tu per favore apri la
porta va maledizione mi aprì con la
porta lì per cortesia quelli che stanno
dalla prima volta a volevo farlo
ragazzotto
quanto tempo per la velista porta grazie
gentile passo è grazie ciao
vado potente ma non ci possono mai qua
sotto così ma che schifo come è
possibile
boh cos'è qua che schifo diventato io
volevo regalarti una scatola che me ne
foti sta scatola bellissimo che non c'è
un posto sotto un posto sopra di lui
sfonda c'è lui dovunque si mette va bene
aspetta cos'è allora l'interruttore
rotto acqua o la melma che bello
allegava e allegro dai basta uniforme di
schifo
apri
e pronto il pollo il collettore afor
rafforzante però devo buttare qua dentro
il culo no aiutato fuoco grazie
c'è un caso che va a fuoco come lo tengo
io mi sa che dovrò eccolo li dovevo fare
questo anno dovevo tirarlo e poi
riprenderlo al volo perché sono si
attivano i cosi cielo fare un casino
praticamente dagli fuoco molto bene
no ho sbagliato sono un pirla rifacciamo
farà quelli che mi guardano da sopra
pochino
spara lo so e riprendilo eccolo 8
mamma mia che ricevitore occhio
mammamia proprio lui un cestista signori
e va a fuoco
non so bene neanche cosa mi sembrano
l'ho preso perchè sicuramente buttaci
dentro le fiamme c'è scritto lì bene
tieni è esploso tutto si apre permesso
perché tutti mi guardano come se facessi
schifo ma reietto a zia e così ha negato
che io abbia fatto è un carretto di
cavoli lattuga erba cosa coltivate qua è
mamma mia
li vedo cosa che fanno quelli di fare
sta facendo sta tentando di catturarmi
cos'è che sono un pokémon cosa che fai
salita sopra
cosa vuoi fare quell'altro guarda che ti
stacco tutta la roba qua e sam attacco
tra l'attacco tutta però che non ha
capito appendi t ecco la mia attacco io
mamma mia 8.000 kg di baby cristiano di
cristiani anzi ragazzi sta per venire
giù il muro agenti fondo bel ali minchia
eos e stati poi ad agganciare cosa mica
io e stupidi ma poi colpa mia ma quando
monta una forza incredibile sta roba
ciao stato bello
qual è il capo si no
amica questa debbo attivare quella devo
tenere in alto un macello aspetta come
si attiva
mi sa che gliela devo tirare a lui
l'attiva lui si si lo vedo so che devo
farmi fare ma vi vogliono aiutare loro
non ho mica capito tieni attiva mela per
favore poiché i rame laggiù grazie e
gentile dai
mammamia teamwork mano come ma mi chiama
si è chiusa subito la porta senti
scusami ho sbagliato mi dispiace non
volevo farle perdere tempo mi scusi però
ho sbagliato mela reattiva per favore
magari attivi il secondo grazie mi scusi
eh ecco giorno tutti bambini che
guardano salve cosa mi prende per il
culo questa roba non ci arrivo ed andate
a cagare appunto ti guardano lì a vedere
qualche modo devo arrivarci non ci
arrivo è diventata un intrattenimento
cos'è il gioco delle giostre quello
degli deve appendere questa roba
ma hanno [ __ ]
va beh
fatto io mi libero uguale non è che cosa
vi credete umani schifosi
cosa vi credete che non sa uscire para
qua mi stacco tutto il 18 vista
boom conte durata st prigioniera 0 60
secondi praticamente che bella possino
prenda a schiaffi tutti quanti poi
cedere alcuni che mi aiutavano altri no
una massa informe di corpi schifosi
salve sono sempre io sono nell'hangar
dei cosi vabbè
no
perché stiamo andando ragazze aiuto ce
l'ha poi vabbè vabbè sponda lo sfonda
tutto tira la madonna aspetta che arrivò
la figlia rincorsa big in corsa vai
rotola pronta la rotola rotola che va
bene che caricano demonio aiuto sono
uscito bravo in montagna consideravamo
sott'acqua prima e dai bowling simulator
una palla una polpetta sull'oceano
questa è poesia
questa è energia quindi a via già a
questo finale
acea ha già famiglie dicevo valle
succederà non ho già è vero mi riferiva
finisce finisce così che tu dici ma
scusami no vediamo che succederà
qualcosa il bambino spiegherà non
spiegano una sega non dicono un cazzo
non si sa che palla e non si sa che ore
sono
non devo dire che sono le so perché sono
le 7 45
non so niente della mia vita però
insight finisce così signore da uno
schermo parte di titoli ricordano sto
scherzando me lo ricordo che fino a così
sono scemo hai visto
beppe carsen cosa affatto visto
ci sono io non so questa tacche ragazzi
è questa un'altra tacca signori non
fatelo ma non chiedete fate non dite
niente tanto non so non so non saprei
spiegarmi nulla però questo era inside
gioco a mio parere incredibile anche a
livello tecnico pazzesco anche a livello
artistico ulteriormente un affresco però
io il finale non l'ho capito e continua
a non capirlo
c'erano allora deduco che l'essere umano
per esso arrivato a questo punto di
desolazione deduco ci sia stata
un'apocalisse quindi gli esseri umani
rimanenti avevano fatto alla fatto con
unity suo gioco bello
deduco che l'essere umano abbia cercato
di trovare un qualche ma qualche
soluzini lo so questo problema tramite
gli esperimenti che facevano sugli
esseri umani stessi perché siano esseri
umani robotizzati poi c'erano quelli che
spiegava sott'acqua e le polpette quelli
che stanno sul vetro a sbattere la testa
contro il vetro
o facevano esperimenti insomma io ero un
bambino stupido sono finito polpetta
questo è inside e poi riparte
dall'inizio è talmente materico questo
finale talmente energico energia energia
mamma mia ragazzi che gioco bellissimo
belle non si capisce un cazzo ma è
bellissimo
ora subito subì ma proprio su ma neanche
faccio passare un minuto che leggo
questa era la mia teoria l'inside di
come della trama
adesso vado sono e schermi the row però
vado a cercare vado a cercare di come la
trama come dovrebbe essere la trama ve
la dico ok allora inside trama minchia
un chilometro di trama va bene
un chilometro sta tra maturato se voi
pensate
la trama di inside sarà una riga no io
me la lego se volete chiudere il video
chiedete a lei perché devo capire dopo
due ore e quarantasette devo capire che
cosa è successo allora le ho finito due
volte 28 il gioco ambientato in una
città il gioco ambientato in una città
dal clima instabile in un futuro
distopico in cui esistono tecnologie
meccaniche chimiche molto avanzate ma in
cui mezzi di raccolta e trasmissione
informazioni sono i nastri magnetici e
grossi computer poi nel giocatore nei
panni di un bambino in un bosco che sta
scappando da qualcosa io stavo scappando
qualcosa all'inizio che si imbatte in
degli uomini con una maschera che
sembrano far parte di una società forza
in un regime autoritario
tali uomini sanno che il bambino sto
scappando e hanno l'ordine di minarla
vista con ogni mezzo a disposizione
fermarlo strangolarlo sparargli uscito
nel bosco il bambino arriva in compagnia
di una campagna come in campo la vision
dozzina di carcasse di maiale
altrettanti video sparisce libero nel
maiale parassita
abbiamo pensato spiega proprio tutta la
trama quello che abbiamo per ha giocato
ci voglio capire cosa è successo
striale i veicoli il bambino ci di
muoversi dentro le case vadano a farsi
scoprire va bene tra cui è stata
tantissimi mesi fatti di cani capitano
doni intruso si sposta gradualmente si
va meno scende per i frequenti spiega
cosa abbiamo giocato ok già all'inizio
però non avevo capito che così non è
non spegne comunque qualsiasi col gioco
non era quelle teorie sul finale perché
non si capisce però ok marco manuali già
fatto per gioco grazie alla nazione si
terrà sul finale giornalisti ed i
giornalisti e giocatori hanno ipotizzato
diverse teorie sul finale dei più
importanti sono quattro a non è dato
sapere se il giocatore dopo tale
sequenza al bambino al giocatore se il
bambino uscirà dalla massa per dare una
risoluzione finale a ciò che ha
preceduto esempio entrano nel crepuscolo
aggiungendo una bambina che lo stava una
bambina che sta aspettando quindi questo
qua non lo leggo è semplicemente
ti spiega cosa abbiamo appena giocato ok
teorie 1 il bambino è controllato per
buona parte del gioco dalla massa
organica del finale il bambino è
controllato da uno più scienziati il
bambino è controllato nella forza
rinnegata rappresentata dal giocatore
il bambino è controllato solo a ok ok
quindi le teorie su che cosa succede da
quando entri nella massa organica ok è
controllato da dalla massa organica del
finale ok il bambino controllato lavoro
più scienziati sul finale non penso
proprio che viene contrato da una forza
rinnegata
credo di sì il bambino è controllato
solo appar un workshop persone in cui
nega a anche quando sono annegato dovevo
controllare inside possiede un finale
alternativo che può essere ottenuto
raccogliendo 14 misteriose sfere
elettriche nascosti chi non onora con
tam ancona rigiocando quando va bene
attraversale inizio in grappoli il campo
di andato via nascosta una botola in
mezzo alle parrocchie che conduce un
bunker sotterraneo ad assistere a
passaggio porta una camera oscura
mostrando foto di masse prodotte dagli
esperimenti passati a destra via la
porta blindata che può essere spostata
ad essere una volta aperta essa conduce
non ero abbastanza fatiscente
somigliando rifugio anti atomico si può
notare in fondo a essa una scrivania con
appoggiati sopra una moltitudine di
schermi di computer ha attaccato subito
c'è uno degli elementi usati al bambino
per controllare le persone prigioniere
del regime a cui sono stati attaccati
kharja se il bambino viene guidato verso
ruolo adesso troverà un grosso cavo che
collega due tempi a tre bunker se il
tale cavo viene staccato intra visuale
si spegna mostrando come ultima cosa al
bambino che controlla il in ginocchio
immobile senza più muoversi che crolla
scusatemi sulla tela iuta tale finale
rinforza la teoria per quale il bambino
dopo la morte per annegamento continuavo
versi sotto controllo di un dispositivo
collegato a una rete quindi realtà
quando io sono annegato in reatà non ero
più io era un altro si provi non ho
capito io non ho capito
[Musica]
il discorso di cech esperimenti facevano
non ho capito gli esperi cioè nel senso
è un futuro distopico quello letto però
non ho capito perché facevano
esperimenti chi sono io questo non lo
spiegano non è dato saperlo perché stavo
scappando da che cosa perché fanno
questi esperimenti dove volevano
arrivare con la massa organica che cosa
era cioè queste cose non le spiegano
proprio non c'è neanche scritto qua va
bene vediamo se stanno facendo un altro
gioco tipo inside al 2010 inside and me
10 limbo 2016 inside perfetto il terzo
gioco di playdead ha annunciato nel
gennaio 2007 sarà un a detta di genzano
un gioco fantascientifico abbastanza
solitario da qualche parte nell'universo
che figo quindi stanno prove stanno
facendo un altro gioco ambientato
nell'universo quindi non limbo know
inside un altro gioco figo contento
bello non ho capito una sega però ho
capito la cei finale sempre
non lo so cioè non ho capito
boh
[Musica]